hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the first round
of the ftx crypto cup it is anish giri
vs magnus carlsen and this is the third
game of their match first two games
ended in a draw and this one features
none other than the french defense in
the first game where magnus had the
black pieces uh magnus played the g6 he
went for an offbeat opening uh but now
as the first two games ended in a draw
uh he decided to take things seriously
and decided to challenge anish to uh
well to a very very deadly line of the
french defense but who better to test it
against
than the great theoretician uh such as
anish giri so let's dive straight into
it as there is quite a lot to enjoy in
this game with e4 e6 going for the
french defense d4d5 knight sorry not
knight to c3 we've had so many unite the
c3s that i thought it was played in this
game as well but rather e5 on each goes
for the advanced variation not um some
sort of a crazy uh invert variation we
have c5 c3 and not knight to c6 we have
knight to f3 and now bishop to d7 by
magnus here queen to b6 is still uh the
the most popular move just putting
pressure on d4 also putting pressure on
b2 but first bishop to d7 bishop to e2
and now knight g to e7 and this is uh
especially useful since anish already
played bishop to e2 so you don't have
bishop on d3 controlling f5 and g6 and
the knight on f5 will be a monster
putting more pressure on d4 this knight
attacks d4 you're gonna play queen b6
put more pressure on uh d4 and if any uh
ever wants to get rid of this knight
from f5 he will have to play g4 and then
the game really opens up nicely so on
each castles and now we have c captures
on d4 again uh this is uh by far more
popular but magnus first goes for the
trade c characters we have c captures
and only now knight to f5
uh knight to c3 and now rook the c8 we
have king to h1 a nice prophylactic move
by anish it's hard to say if it's
necessary in this position but i mean
it's always it's always a good idea the
queen and bishop when the position opens
up uh you don't want your king on on
on a dark square here so here a6 by
magnus not allowing knight to b5 and now
we have bishop the g5 again there is one
game where g4 was played just uh
eliminating this knight from from f5 but
on each place bishop to g5 and it is now
as of movie 11 that we have a completely
new game so how will magnus continue
here here goes queen b6 this is where
the queen belongs and uh now that the
light square bishop dark square bishop
has been developed the queen comes into
the game with temple attacking the b2
pawn also this pawn is attacked three
times so what can anish play you could
play bishop to e3 go for some sort of a
queen captures on b2
uh sort of uh maybe a poison pawn
variation but not really uh but instead
and he goes for knight a4 right away uh
this prevents black from start capturing
on d4 as the queen is hanging and also
the knight on a4 nicely defends the b2
pawn so queen back to a7 looks like a
weird square for the queen but you've
seen in many openings that the queen can
actually have a very very comfortable
game tucked away on a7 like this like in
some lines of the scandinavian that
we've shown so bishop back to e3
defending d4 and now magnus could
eliminate the bishop right away and
claim the bishop pair but for the moment
this knight is much much stronger than
this bishop and there is no reason to
rush this so bishop to e7 continuing
development and now pawn to a3 with pawn
to b5 chasing the knight back knight to
c3 and now only now magnus castles king
side and now uh bishop to d3 saying that
an attack is definitely coming with uh
white having control over g5 maybe g4
can be played at some point uh opening
up the position the queen can come maybe
to h5 so if you allow an issue one one
good move uh or rather if you play a bad
one uh you know things might go wrong
things might go very wrong for you so
knight captures on e3 magnus finally
eliminates this bishop f captures and
now pawn to b4 opening up the position a
captures knight captures now attacking
the light square bishop and
interestingly anish doesn't uh tuck the
bishop away bishop to b1
does seem like an automatic here but he
decides against it he plays pawn to e4
uh he opens up the position and he
allows
the elimination of the light square
bishop so magnus happily captures at
night captures queen captures and now d
captures an e4 knight captures an e4 so
what has anish gained by giving up the
both of his bishops uh well his knights
are very very active now the knights can
come to g5 also some uh
sacrificing unite to f6 is possible and
you have to be very very careful here
for example yes your a6 pawn is also
hanging but let's say you play pawn to
a5 it seems like a good idea uh already
knight to g5 and you will have a very
very hard time defending this it's um uh
probably it's lost for black but maybe
you know with some miraculous play you
can save this uh point being that uh
let's say play something like h6 just
knight f6 check and it's game over once
the knight is captured the other knight
also covers h7 the bishop captures or g
captures this will be checkmate so now
you can defend but you have to play g6
weaken your position even further and
then you're gonna have a really bad game
so instead after knight captures on e4
magnus takes away the g5 square from the
knights he weighs some with h6 point
being that for the moment uh
uh his a6 pawn is defended with a tactic
if rook captures on a6 queen b8 is
beautiful puts pressure on b2 but really
what you are doing is preparing bishop
to b5 with the queen on d3 and rook on
f1 uh this is terrible for for white so
on each spot this he plays rook fd1 gets
one of the rooks away from
this diagonal and now pawn to a5 now
this is very much playable we have queen
to d2 by anish again putting pressure on
the a5 pawn uh but now magnus plays
bishop to c6 he uh here anish probably
is even baiting magnus a little bit to
play bishop to b4 kind of seems like a
good idea but then queen captures on b4
and of course magnus can resign if a
capture through captures on a7 you're
down a full piece this is resigns so
after queen to d2 bishop to c6 the
bishop finally assumes this spectacular
diagonal and now comes queen to f4
anisha has to
build up the attack because the
immediate knight to f6 check although
you really want to play this uh still
doesn't work magnus will just move the
king and uh you know it's worth
exploring for example queen d3 you
threaten checkmate you kind of force the
capture on g6 now you play queen back to
d2 uh attack the the pawn here now king
h7 and if d3 check f5 black defense and
the there's no actual attack
happening here so instead bishop c6
anish improves his position queen to f4
now queen to b8 just putting pressure on
the b2 pawn hoping to create uh
a passer and of course if rook captures
we again have bishop to b4 because the
rooks are now on dark squares as you can
see rooks really don't go along uh very
well with with your opponent's bishops
uh so rookie two uh defending the b2
pawn and also putting a rook on a light
square and now pawn to a4 now the bishop
nicely defends the pawn here queen to g4
now knight to f6 might be a bit more
potent but magnus says not really just
queen b5 goes after the rook here and
now rook f2 does seem to be the way to
go for anish but he plays rook 8 to e1
and he misses uh well he doesn't miss i
think he's actually baiting bishop to b4
to go for the attack uh
thinking that maybe it works maybe
magnus will not have time to calculate
or maybe
magnus will just be afraid who knows i
mean yeah once you
once you don't really have all that many
options you have to go for something so
bishop to be for magnus is not afraid he
leaves this um
diagonal and the bishop on e7 was a
monster regarding uh f6 guarding g5 but
he says it is not a problem and anish
now has to decide whether to go for
knight to f6 check and it is quite uh
quite a move you could also consider
knight d6 attacking queen and the rook
kind of forcing bishop captures uh
on d6 creating a pass pawn but again it
doesn't bring him all that much the real
uh
line to calculate his knight f6 check
king the h8 and now knight the h5
threatening checkmate on g7 rook to g8
and now it seems like black defended but
what about knight to g5 so you even have
to take this into consideration now
threatening knight captures an f7
luckily magnus can capture here and not
after queen to h3 threatening knight to
f7 a discovered checkmate uh you have
this beautiful the only move that saves
the game for magnus g4 now once the
queen leaves this diagonal you can just
start capturing or if queen to h4 still
threatening checkmate now you have even
g5 so at some point you will have to
capture now i play bishop captures an e1
and there's no good way to play this
knight f6 okay you're still threatening
something queen d3 we are bringing the
queen back to help out with a defensive
queen h5 checking g7 queen g5 uh there's
queen g6 and now you're just down
material captures captures and of course
through characters on e1 but once you
count the pieces uh magnus would be up a
whole rook so uh it's a good move uh but
if black defends properly and chances
are magnus would defend properly uh the
attack just doesn't work
so anish prepares it he plays d5 and
it's a standard
standard trick when attacking black's
king and especially in structures like
these
if you can gain access to the f5 square
with your queen you you will be winning
and here if magnus actually captures
with the pawn then knight f6 is winning
uh you have to move the king this is the
only move king h8 and now queen f5 you
threaten checkmate and now you force
this capture once this is captured you
play this captures with czech king h7
now knight d4 bringing the knight to f5
with tempo is now the queen is hanging
and there's no good move here queen d3
knight f5 we're threatening checkmate so
you either have to give up the queen or
you play rook g8 and now of course queen
captures on h6 is checkmate so that
that's uh kind of uh the idea anish had
uh when playing this d5 move uh it's a
move that doesn't really do anything
unless magnus captures uh uh you know uh
uh e capture sun on d5 but magnus of
course will not do that he just grabs
the rook bishop captures on e1 knights
the d4 attacks the bishop and the queen
now but not just queen to d3 uh so what
do you play uh rook captures on e1
grabbing back the piece now bishop
captures on d5 we have knight to f6
check finally uh leaving magnus the only
move that is king to h8 and now knight
captures on d5 uh but now queen to d2 a
beautiful beautiful uh spot by magnus
the rook is now hanging so what do you
play and each plays rook to d1 attacks
the queen but now rook the c1
threatening captures captures and
checkmate or the other way around
captures captures in checkmate on each
defends with knight to c3 now the rook
is nicely defended but i'm sure you guys
can pretty much solve this one without
even pausing but just in case you know
maybe there are
new chess players watching
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for magnus while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh deciding to
give up the queen and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course queen to e1 check and as its
check made in two moves uh it was in
this position on move 34 that anish giri
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once the queen is
accepted and this is the only move for
white magnus plays rook capture sunny
one and this is now checkmate so uh as
you can see it
it is definitely questionable a question
about whether that king the h1 the
prophylactic idea that we discussed was
uh you know all that great uh but of
course the game would take a completely
different turn if the king was on g1 and
there are many other winning options
here for magnus as well
so after queen to e1 check on each
resigned and magnus wins the third game
and as magnus also won the fourth game
it means that magnus won his match
against tanish geary uh so that's
basically what happened uh in their in
their match first two games in the draw
and then magnus won the other two games
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it like i said uh never
play the french unless you really really
excel at it because you will just you
know crumble your your position will
be unplayable very very quickly you know
even after a few moves i mean i dare you
try playing the french online uh go to
leeches go to chess.com you know play a
three minute blitz game yeah play the
fringe defense uh yeah
it's not going to be pretty uh but if
you can play it like magnus then of
course it is very much playable uh so
yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank peter
rodriguez alex varsilio francis air
ricky yemeni and excellent subscriber
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event uh until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and don't worry i will upload the chess
master grandmaster edition against
stockfish probably tomorrow morning
see you soon